[Music]
i was talking with
um
one of elena's really good friends
and i was saying that i think
most frat dudes
on paper have done more gay things than
most gay guys by age 20.
yeah okay like what by age 20 like more
frat dudes have done like i don't know
[ __ ] elephant walks and like stood
naked with each other or made each other
drink piss like
did coke piss is gay yeah
i mean
okay drinking p is not gay necessarily
but like if drinking piss is gay then
i'm elton john
[Laughter]
all right yeah
well
yeah let's let's what let's unpack wait
what yeah let's unpack that dude if it
if a if a
dude older than you
he's in a cup
and you're like shirtless in a basement
of an old frat house and he's like drink
this [ __ ] pledge you're like okay
that's at least a kink
like on paper i don't think that
actually happens
i don't think fat dudes drink each other
each other's piss i don't think
that's weird man that's what i'm saying
can you give people like stds and [ __ ]
i think he's no i'm saying like as a
drinking pee yeah like isn't aren't you
i know it's sterile but aren't you also
risking no it's not sterile that's a
myth yeah it's not sterile that's what
i'm saying yeah
i mean yeah that's not what i said but i
mean that's what i thought i've heard
that before that it's not sterile yeah
and that you can get like like throat
diseases and [ __ ] from doing that
yeah but how bad do you want to be in
beta sigma nu pretty bad i guess
what about calm do they
no that was your friend
you're just sitting here the whole time
dude p never yeah we only used con
wait what
what i mean if drinking [ __ ] is gay then
i mean
come on what world are we in
yeah
i want to see the new top gun just
because you know
i also don't have my own opinions and
everyone says it's good so i want to see
i want to see what's good
um
i wonder what people are so excited
about in it
apparently it's really intense
that's what i've
heard this first scene just two guys
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of each other on a
volleyball court a 99 audience score 99
these are bots
you think so dude have you ever looked
at
everything is bots now everything bro
online sucks now yeah
like i'm serious like i'm almost like
reddit is i almost just said that
reddit's like the only place with real
people wait you think there's bots on
reddit too
yeah
you think so yeah yeah probably there
probably is yes at least they're a
little bit more intelligent they're like
the twitter ones are they like they're
trained
with maybe ai or language processing or
something like that
build their own sentences sure and tweet
things that align with a certain
sentiment or whatever but like instagram
and tick talk and youtube which every
time you post anything it's like
it's [ __ ]
don't click my profile
oh i just posted a really saucy story
yeah
i hope they not gotten rid of those yet
yeah probably because like
they need that
for online to feel populated
maybe if you just left online to like
people who are actually online it would
just look like vr chat it's just wildly
insensitive and it's the way you think
reddit
yeah i think it's got bots for sure do
you guys think it has bots
there's definitely bots on reddit like
comments from people yeah i don't know
what reddit is i don't know i don't know
if they're replying to people in real
time but i do think there are bots to be
like i love this song you guys are
haters this song is dope oh yeah okay i
see what you're saying yeah there
definitely is i don't get the hate this
[ __ ] slaps i i just i mostly mean like
you can't trust
like if i want
if i want people's honest opinion about
something i search
blank
reddit
not fortunate
i don't trust reviews on imdb rotten
tomatoes i feel like everything is just
can be gamed now and bought and cam
but
have you ever read audience score
reviews those are funny
no
on rotten tomatoes yeah someone's like
click the thing and then yeah yeah let's
read one from reading a couple zoom in
excellent movie
lots of intensity well done excellent
movie i love this see that's not a real
person yeah this is yeah that's awesome
movie did a wonderful job as sequel
we'll definitely see it again and again
okay susan w
okay thrilling movie experience what is
this
i feel the need period to go see it
again so yeah that it bots for sure wow
just wow this movie is incredible best
film i've watched in ages the sequels
was worth the 30 year wait
third it's been 30 years
it's been 84 years
that actually
probably he's tom cruise is like 50
something and he's yes
tom cruise was 24 when the first one
came out
and he's still doing that's cringe
that's gonna be us 55 that's cringe the
return
yeah
that's cringe the movie
damn didn't these [ __ ] do this in
like
2015 or something
it's 20 45. this is we're both just like
bald and fast holy [ __ ]
the difference is tom cruise is like
still jacked lived up to the hype it was
a great movie see it on the big screen
with great sound
don't wait for it to stream okay that
[ __ ] you no you don't see that rick see
that you don't know [ __ ] dude that is
the studio burner for sure no this movie
is really good don't wait for it to like
definitely go see it opening yeah
definitely go love this movie i'm an 80s
teenager so i did i did like this we
don't know
but this one yeah don't need your life
story dog boring
all right
this was just this was just as good as
the first top gun yeah because you don't
remember the first one it's been long
enough
yeah definitely see this one in theaters
if you go to a theater and leave you're
a piece of [ __ ] oh interesting
what best movie ever cody co you dumb
[ __ ] don't you watch it at home you dumb
piece of [ __ ]
read this when i say stay in the theater
you [ __ ] idiot whoa
it's the first movie i've sent
i've sent yeah gpt not working out right
here yeah seriously at the cinema in two
years and it was definitely worth the
wait so intense
had me coming in what
had me drinking piss it was so good what
the hell
so intense had me sitting on the edge of
my seat the whole time have these people
like never watched mma or something epic
movie yeah yeah yeah
yeah your opinion sucks
[Laughter]
leading with epic movie goodbye
yeah now you're out of here
we don't care
whole family loved it just kidding i
don't have a family
it's just a link to his cash app oh no
i don't have a family please send money
what's russ got to say yeah scroll down
a little bit wait didn't we just read
this exact
oh yeah yeah see our pina r
oh
well that's a good one arpina yeah
our penis must be sucked
[Applause]
[Music]
you